hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar help protect what matters design
and performance of alinity m transplant
assays cmv and ebv
i'm cece valdez of labyrinths and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by scientific affairs molecular
diagnostics at abbott and the program is
sponsored by global scientific affairs
molecular diagnostics at abbott to learn
more visit molecular.abbott.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd now like to welcome our speaker dr
rick nolte
professor
emeritus in the department of pathology
laboratory medicine at the medical
university of south carolina
dr nolte welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
well welcome everyone um to this webinar
we're going to talk about design and
performance of validity m transplant
assays for cytomegalovirus and
epstein-barr
virus go through these standard
disclosures the support for this program
is provided by abbott i am speaking at
the request of abbott and of the
cmv and ebv
assays are ce marked and available for
diagnostic use in ce marked regions only
so what are we going to try to cover
today we're going to do brief
descriptions of disease diseases caused
by both cmv and ebb
we're going to talk about the design of
the alinity m assays for these two
viruses
we're going to talk a lot about the
performance characteristics of the two
essays and finally we're going to
focus on some of the advantages that the
m offers in terms of laboratory workflow
uh the
disease overview portion of the talk
we'll start with cmv
it's cmv it's
a linear double-stranded dna virus with
a rather large genome 235 kilobases
encoding approximately 165 genes
um we know
that the cmv dna in plasma and blood is
no is is highly fragmented so we don't
have that large genome floating around
free in the blood for serum
there's also for a dna virus cmv has a
high degree of genetic diversity with
frequent mutations arising
when the virus is grown in cell culture
and also
within and
between infected individuals
individuals can be reinfected as a
result of this genetic diversity recon
individuals can be reinfected with
different strains of cmv
cmv syndrome and disease it's an
important cause of morbidity and
mortality and solid organ transplant
recipients
the infection and disease typically
occurs during the first three months
after solid organ transplant
its most common presentation is the
so-called cmv syndrome which typically
manifests to fever malaise atypical
lymphocytosis leukopenia or neutropenia
thrombocytopenia and elevated hepatic
transaminases
end organ cnb disease uh usually or
most likely it's to occur in the
transplanted allograft but it also can
affect other organs
within a transplant recipient the
gastrointestinal tract
the lungs the pneumonia hepatitis
nephritis myocarditis pancreatitis
encephalitis
retinitis and other
organ systems less frequently
it's thought that cmv disease develops
in it today in about 10 percent patients
undergoing hematopoietic stem cell
transplant
and another important point is around
preemptive and prophylactic use of high
potency antiviral drugs for cmvs like
gannon cyclovir they have been shown to
result in increased risk of late cmv
disease in both transplant populations
let's move on to epstein-barr virus
it's a double-stranded dna virus just
like cmb it's one of the most common
human-associated viral infections it's
estimated that 95 of the world's adult
population
has been infected by edd
the primary infection with ebv is
generally asymptomatic
but
can lead to infectious mononucleosis and
adolescence in young adults
uh following the primary infection the
virus established as a lifelong latency
or persistent infection in b cells
the first time you get infected with dbv
you can transmit the virus for weeks
even before you have symptoms once the
virus is in your body
uh it stays there in a latent inactive
state
and if the virus reactivates you can
potentially spread edd to others no
matter how much time has passed since
the initial infection
so the main problem with ebv in
transplant recipients is the so-called
post-transplant lymphofiliperative
disease
ptld for short
it's associated with ebv in 90
of um
cases and it's a serious illness which
can often
occur and immuno suppress transplant
recipients
in fact it's the most common malignancy
that occurs in transplant recipients
the roots of transmission for cmv and
evv are very similar they include
a transplant recipient a positive donor
an organ from a positive donor
vertical transmission can occur from
mother to child in utero during delivery
or by breast milk
cmv particularly is
can be
transmitted through sexual
contact with an infected partner as well
as
can be ebv
exposure to a variety of body fluids
blood blood products saliva and urine so
these represent the primary roots of
transmission of viruses
manifestations of infection so as we
mentioned once
infected the person carries the virus
for life which may be reactivated from
time to time usually with little effect
on the the individual
for the vast majority of people cmv or
epv infection is not a serious problem
unless the person's immune system is
suppressed due to therapeutic drugs
a disease an immunosuppressive disease
an immature immune system particularly
in congenital infections
and
as we've already alluded to infection
with cmv and ebv is a major cause of
disease in depth in immunocompromised
patients
let's talk a little bit about the role
of viral load monitoring and transplant
patients for these two viruses
uh this is a sort of a generalization
generalization
uh slide it can be used for both cmv and
and ebv
um obviously the donor and recipient are
are
tested for their
infection status for both viruses
typically via serology
once that's been established
the transplant procedure is done
and then where viral load monitoring
comes in
is in the patient management
post transplantation
looking a little closer at how that
might work
this is a slide
focused specifically on cmv
monitoring and
treatment in the solid organ transplant
and the
bone marrow transplant patient
population
typically in solid organ transplant
programs
the antiviral drug
is
bowel can cycle here usually it's um
administered for a defined period of
time post transplantation uh typically
from three to twelve months depending
upon the type of solid organ transplant
um the schedule of monitoring also can
depend upon the type of organ transplant
uh lung transplant recipients since they
are
among the most heavily
immunosuppressed solid organ transplant
population
typically will monitor their patients on
a weekly basis
for up to a year post-transplantation
kidney transplantation
not so much
routine monitoring use more like a
diagnostic test when a
patient presents with a co cmv syndrome
or another manifest
potential manifestation of
end organ disease
if we move on to the the stem cell
transplant population
uh really we're talking about preemptive
therapy
the patients are most at risk for
serious outcomes with c and v disease
before the bone marrow totally ingress
and that typically takes about 100 days
so during that 100 days post
transplantation
these patients are frequently monitored
either once or twice a week depending
upon the program for cmd viral load and
then
um
late
as a guard against patients developing
late
cmv disease they are monitored at
regular intervals after that first
hundred days
let's talk a little bit about some of
the challenges associated with viral
load testing for cmv ebv next
so the application and range of nucleic
acid
amplification test
used in the diagnosis and management of
cmv varies significantly
higher viral load
correlates with increased risk for
disease
but given the heterogeneity of nucleic
acid-based systems it is difficult to
compare viral load measurements between
different laboratories to develop
uniform
intervention thresholds or treatment
strategies so really
the particular
clinical
site
and the various assays are used across
clinical sites need to be taken into
account
when
thinking about developing thresholds for
intervention
quantitative nucleic acid results should
be demonstrated to be linear in the
clinically important range between the
lower and upper limits of quantification
uh precision of quantitative nucleic
acid tests
results are such that they are
changes in values should be at least
threefold or 0.5 log
of change to represent a biologically
important change in viral replication
and when you get down to the lower end
of the measurement range down to around
the thousand international units per mil
the changes uh the precision of the
assays tends to be not as good
so changes may need to be greater than
fivefold or 0.7 logs to be considered
significant
yeah continuing on with the challenges
of nucleic acid testing in cnb
we
all know that serology is not used in
diagnosis of active cmv replication
and disease post-transplantation
quantitative nucleic acid amplification
testing in blood is preferred for
diagnosis and monitoring of cnb
infection and disease
qualitative results should be available
optimally within 24 to 48 hours
to optimize clinical decision making
both plasma and whole blood specimens
are used for quantitative nucleic acid
testing
and typically patients are monitored one
to
one to two times a week based on their
risk for developing cmv disease
for highly sensitive assays in which the
limit of quantitation is less than 200
international units per mill
multiple very low
results might be
sufficient
um
to make a decision to stop therapy so
you could
um see how anastasia with exquisite
sensitivity
um you may
not require it require it to be
not detected
to measure a clinical response
if we go to the hematopoietic stem cell
patient population
you have to remember before the advent
of viral load monitoring and
preemptive therapy in this population
the leading cause of death post bone
marrow transplantation was actually cmv
disease
so quantitative nucleic acid testing in
the blood is preferred for diagnosis and
monitoring of infection and disease
um
we already talked about the specimen
type microbrethrosis for plasmid but
some labs are still using whole blood
we already touched on this point the
first hundred days post-transplant which
is
the time when the patients are at most
risk for cnb disease and it should be
done at least on a weekly basis
um longer monitoring periods beyond that
first 100 days is recommended in
patients with acute
or chronic graft versus host disease and
those having experienced
cmv reactivation
in patients having undergone mismatched
transplant
cord blood
uh haploidentical um
bone marrow transplant or or
hematopoietic stem cell transplant
uh and in those on long term uh
effective prophylactics
or in those suspending persistent
immunodeficiency
uh with the viral load having the
potential to double within um two days
or less
it in
promotes the frequent testing of these
patients in anticipation of them
eventually needing preemptive therapy
let's move on to to ebv
and ptld
so ebv viral load monitoring is done
primarily as an early indicator
of those patients who may develop
post-transplant
proliferative disorder so perspective
monitoring dbv dna is performed again by
quantitative pcr
there's no consensus on the specimen
type here many labs are still using cold
blood
we our lab the last
year and a half switched from whole
blood to plasma as a specimen type um
and it was
sort of a welcome change by the
clinicians because they weren't bothered
by
us reporting persistent low levels of
ebv dna in whole blood
uh the calculated
doubling time for ebv is as short as 56
hours but
longer than cmv um so
this kind of gives you some uh
basis for frequent monitoring in
patients with rising ebd dna
levels in the blood
um
yeah the the um frequency of food which
you may
want to monitor these patients is
dependent depending upon the donor and
the recipient status
uh those patients who receive a donor
positive organ that are
the recipient is
negative or at highest risk for
developing ptld
and they should be monitored more
frequently than those
where the donor is negative and the
recipient is negative
weekly or twice weekly monitoring with
the first year
or at least first months after solid
organ transplant is
recommended okay now we're going to dive
into some of the specifics about the
alinity m cmv and ebv assays
we'll start first with the ebb assay
design
uh both tests are in vitro polymerase
chain reactions
[Music]
test
quantitative
assays that can be used on both plasma
and whole blood specimen types
they are intended for use as aid and
diagnosis
and management of both infections and
transplant and other immunocompromised
patients
the intended use in conjunction with
clinical presentation and other
laboratory markers as an indicator of
initiation of therapy and for use as an
aide in monitoring viral
response to therapy as measured by
changes in viral load and either plasma
or whole blood
neither test is intended for use in
screening blood blood products tissue or
organ donors for either virus
why why choose the alinity m pass phase
over some of the other assays that might
be on the market
uh target selection and probe design
optimized nucleic acid extraction
process
the calibration and data reduction
strategies that um
the alinity m assays use and we'll get
into that
next
so both assays
include target specific probes for cmv
and ebv
and internal probe the probes are
single-stranded
dna fragments that
have both a fluorescent reporter
molecule and a dark hole quencher
in the in solution in the absence of the
specific target
the the probes take a random coil
configuration which keeps the quencher
close to the reporter molecule
and the um
it's important to note that both assays
are dual target design the gene regions
targeted in cmv or ul 34 and ul
80.5 and ebb gp 350 and eev
and a1
this helps to prevent any genotype bias
from introducing any genotype bias into
the assays
what's shown in the lower panel of the
slide is in the presence of the target
the probe binds and the reporter
molecule is sufficiently separated from
the quencher
such that there is after excitation
fluorescence
emitted
and i might add that the dark holy
quenchers since they have no intrinsic
fluorescence do tend to decrease
the background signal in the assets
so
you know this is real-time pcr
so the
fundamental process is something i'm
sure that you're all familiar with the
abbott assays
employ
two calibrators a low and a high
calibrator is is indicated on the
on the slide
they're done in triplicate and the
cycle
number or cycle threshold for each
calibrator is recorded
then you test a patient sample and its
cycle number is compared to the standard
curve
created by calibrator a and calibrator b
and that's how you get the
the concentration in log
international units per mil
in addition the data reduction software
does a number of other things
uh this is a rather complicated slide
i'm going to try to
to give you the the high level view
so there's
habits data reduction software
includes a max ratio method which
compared to fluorescent signal between
um
between cycles for each and every cycle
and it identifies a consistent point or
very
within or very near the exponential
region
of the pcr
growth curve
compared to other analytical techniques
that generate only a cycle number and
relative measures of amplification of
issues c and curve shape
by using these values the max ratio
method can make highly reliable reactive
non-reactive determinations along with
quantitative evaluation particularly at
the low end of the
measurement range
so it's these these other measures the
the
measurement of the cycle number the
relative measurements of application
efficiency and this curve shape
that
leads to the fractional cycle number
that is particularly important in terms
of being
reliable
being able to
assess the reaction efficiency and
really good at
separating background
noise from
true amplification
let's dive into the
the assay performance data next we'll
start with the cmv essay
so here here's a a look at the results
that come up of the cmv essay
specimen type for both plasma and whole
blood
um you can see that the measurement
range is 1.48 to 8 log international
units per ml and plasma
and 1.88 to 8 log international units
per ml in whole blood
the you can get a result of detected
but below the lower limit of
quantification for both specimen types
and they're shown on the slide here
and also above
the upper limit of quantification
you will get a result that is greater
than what the upper limit quantification
is and in both
sample types that's greater than eight
log international units per ml
um the limits of detection there are two
[Music]
two ways that abbott has has established
that
through probit analysis and limiting
dilution studies
and you what you can see in the under
the probit analysis common
column is the limit of detection
determined by that analysis using
one
genotype the gb1 genotype of cmb
the next column
shows what the limit of detection was
established
via a panel
of different genotypes of cmv gb1 gb2
gb3 and gb4
and so the the limit of detection set
for the assay takes into account the
different genotypes that might be
encountered and is 30 international
units per ml for plasma and 75
international units per mil for whole
blood
this shows you um plots of the linear
range
in both plasma and whole blood
um
as we talked about earlier the linear
range
is is not
it has a higher
a little higher
lower limit of quantification than does
the assay and plasma 1 versus 1.48 but
otherwise
the assay
correlates
very well on the target concentration
and the measured concentration for but
in both blood
and
plasma
if you look at the precision uh this is
yeah this was done over um
[Music]
let's see if this is the total standard
deviation the
precision was performed on a minimum of
three instruments run by three operators
using three reagent lots
um with plasma a minimum of 147 ballot
samples
and with undiluted plasma and dilution
series of plasma with 108
147 valid samples at each point
so that similar sort of analysis was
done
with
with
blood
and what you can see is a very good
precision
the standard deviation
um
was less than um
point the total standard deviation was
less than or equal to 0.19 log
international per units per node
in plasma and less than or equal to 0.35
long international
units
per
per
milliliter so quite good standard
deviation if you look at
a clinical
reproducible study reproducibility study
using actual um
clinical
samples
um the
the
the standard deviation still remains
quite low
so this slide presents the results of
comparing the illinity m c and the assay
results with the avid real time cd
assay
and
again you can see quite a high
correlation between the two methods
so the alinity mcmv assay
is
highly correlated with the results from
the m2000 real-time pcr sa
and
the bias between the assay
was was quite small at 0.16
log international
units per milliliter
and a little it was in favor or a little
higher if you will positive buyers uh
positive uh bias for the illinois m cmv
assay but very close
um
this is looking at um previous slide
with plasma uh basically the same sort
of results when you look at whole blood
samples
um and you compare the two avid assays
on the two different platforms
and the the
mean bias
or the mean difference here was 0.32 log
international units per ml for all blood
samples so very similar to plasma
and then finally
in terms of looking at some of the
performance of the
msa it was compared with another
fda
ce marked comparator assay
and the two uh the illini mcmb essay
demonstrate a strong correlation and
and agreement
with the uh with the comparator essay
and again the uh a bias of uh 0.14 log
international units per ml
when the linnady m assay was compared to
a another fda cleared
assay for the same purpose
so summary of the unity m assay dual
target design offers redundancy of
coverage and pro
limits
um
any genotype bias that might be
associated with the assay
it is precise across a broad dynamic
range
it's a sensitive assay that can detect
cmv in both plasma or whole blood
and there is a strong correlation with
the
avid real-time
ptr assay
and the avid felinity msa
with the fda approved comparator
assay
okay i'm going to move on now to the um
the assay the
ebv essay on the illinois m platform
same sort of data that i presented for
the cmv
um we're looking here now at
the reportable results and how they
interpretation of them for both plasma
and whole blood
uh the dynamic range for this assay
is 1.3 to 8.3 logs
in plasma 1.6 8.3 logs
in
in whole blood
you get
target not detected results or you get
results that are detected but below or
above
the upper limit of quantification
again looking at the limits of detection
[Music]
similar data
done
the analysis was done two ways
when you look across the different
genotypes of ebv genotype one and
genotype 2
the lod
is set at 20 international units per mil
in plasma and 40 international units per
mil
in whole
blood
next slide
um again linear range for both plasma
and whole blood um as we mentioned
earlier 1.3 logs 8.3 logs
in plasma
8.3 logs
in um
[Music]
in whole blood uh the linear range was
also determined with ebv this is
genotype 2
with essentially the same results
total standard deviation measured much
in the same way as it was measured for
cytomegalovirus and you can see that the
the total standard deviation here
in plasma is less than or equal to
0.026 log international units per ml
and 0.28 log international units per mil
[Music]
in whole blood
so again the cross comparison between
the two avid platforms the ulinity m and
the m2000 platforms
for measurement of dvd viral load again
you see an excellent core
correlation between the results and um
quite a nice
agreement
the bias here was a little higher than
it was
uh with the with the cnb essay
0.48 log international units per
milliliter
but still within
acceptable
still within an acceptable range
um
[Applause]
so this is the same data presented for
old blood
um a little bit different
good correlation
uh the bias was with it was different
here
it was point minus one
point
one three log international units per
mill
um
for the alinity m assay compared to the
m2000 essay
but still
quite a good agreement
so what can we say about in summary for
the illinois med essay
dual target design offers redundancy of
coverage just like it did in the cmv
essay and prevents or at least
limits the opportunity for genotype bias
it's precise across a broad dynamic
range
it can be used to measure
ebv in both plasma and whole blood
and there's a very good correlation
between
the alinity m and the avid m2000 real
time pcr essay
so yes let's uh let's talk a little bit
about
the alinity and the ready flicks and how
that improves workflow
um our lab has been a
a long time user of the avid m2000
platform
uh we've had the opportunity to um
we had the opportunity to implement the
m2000 i'm sorry the illinois m platform
uh during the height of the uh
um
the covet pandemic so we really got a
good feel for how
the workflow can be improved from going
from m2000 to
to the alinity m platform
so the throughput is about 300 samples
in eight hours
um
that we would need we would need um at
least
three
m2000s to to get to that that same level
of sample input so that was certainly
appreciated during the
unprecedented volumes of testing that we
were doing during the during covet and
continue to do
the turnaround time is much more
more rapid that's why you can get a
greater throughput uh the rapid turnout
around the time from all assays says 115
minutes to the first result
it also has tremendous flexibility
although we used it as our primary
workforce during covid
uh we have validated both the hiv and
the hepatitis c assays
on the alinity m platform
and uh plan to move on to the transplant
viruses once they
gain fda fda approval but this ability
to perform any test at any time
is a is a remarkable advantage
and and the stat prior prioritization we
we
utilize that often and we had critical
patients with suspected sars kobe 2 um
application
but you know as a laboratory director
the batch mode analysis um
doesn't work all that well when you have
a very demanding transplant population
and oftentimes we would get calls
although we would run the essay multiple
times a week
on those on those days when we weren't
offering the test
there would often be requests special
situations where we would have to alter
our schedule to accommodate those
special requests uh that's really no
problem with the alinity m platform so
the combination of the increased
throughput the decrease analysis time
the opportunity to run any test at any
time and the availability
of moving things to the front of the
queue um is really quite a welcomed
improvement uh over the m2000 platform
so finally i guess that brings me to the
end
i'd like to acknowledge my colleague
at medical university of south carolina
dr julie hirschhorn who
was the associate director of the lab
when i was there and she is now the
director of the lab and also the entire
and usc molecular pathology laboratory
staff
and then avid molecular uh dr sarah
jones dominic newelli francis lennon
lisa cole mark
sorry mark
got the name out and i'd also like to uh
thank danielle
as well so thank you very much thank you
very much for your attention
and thank you dr nolte for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar and if you have any questions
you want to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
so let's get started it looks like we
already have some great questions coming
in from our audience members
dr nolte as a lab manager trying to
consolidate diagnostic tests to run on
fewer platforms what assay features do
you think are important for the cmv ebv
viral load testing
yeah that's that's that's a great
question
um you know we went through the last
slide i think highlighted a lot of the
advantages um
for the linnety m system
and um
we'll go through them again
the the fact that the analysis time is
is greatly reduced is is a big plus
the
fact that um
[Music]
multiple
you know sample types for for both ebv
and and cmv are are acceptable both
whole blood and plasma
the um
the fact that you know we have the stack
capability of moving things to the front
of the line
um all i think are important
um in terms of thinking about a platform
moving forward
and you know what drives
my entire last decade of my career
i've been
pushing for consolidation of molecular
platforms in in molecular pathology labs
and
know many of you in in the audience
as well as myself have experienced a
situation where you
have a platform that may or have may may
have one or two assays that are fda
cleared on it
the plan that abbott has moving forward
is quite impressive in terms of the
number of assays they hope
um to develop in a relatively short
period of time for the illinidm
so the lab you know
our lab at musc
had basically um two platforms um i'm
storing three platforms uh the m2000 was
the workhorse platform for all of our
viral load assays
um we have the um a holistic platf
holistic uh platform well i'm sorry a
logic platform
for the sdis
and then basically um
another
platform for orphan assays those assays
that weren't
available on either one of the two
systems
and that was the 3m system so
i hope that answers the question
thank you so much dr nolte and as a
follow-up um
cmv and ebv do not have numerical
thresholds but
rely on institution specific parameters
for patient monitoring and evaluation
what benchmarks would a new platform
need to hit for you to be confident that
the results fit into the evaluation
scheme adopted by the institution or to
potentially lower change the existing
threshold used by the institution and
this audience member says for example
what outcomes these studies would you
need
yeah that's a that's another really good
question and
um you know parallel testing with the um
old and the new assay would probably be
the best way to get at that
and
it's particularly i mean
that now there are you know several
now there are several fda cleared cmv
essays soon to be more
and
even
um you know when you look
between assays from different companies
um
it tends to be a wider or more difficult
problem in terms of
the
the bias that you might introduce by um
switching
um
not only
assays but assay platforms
um and the best way to get it that i
wish you know that's been one of the
biggest
problems in this area
both particularly with ebv
and cmv is that
laboratories a number of years ago
transitioned many laboratories
transitioned from laboratory develop
tests to
fda cleared test
and
there
often are wide differences when you when
you make that um make that leap
and so labs that are still using
laboratory develop tests may have a
harder time
lining up the results between the fda
cleared test and the laboratory
developed tests but the easiest way to
get to that was going to be
by by doing parallel testing
with the different assays for some
period of time and to establish what
that you know difference in results
will be
when the
switch is made and then bring
the clinician users of the essay
into that discussion
to help them interpret you know what the
differences might be
thank you so much dr nolte and i i want
to thank our audience members for these
great great questions coming in we have
time for a few more
this next audience member says kind of
connected to the vl threshold questions
qpcr assays have become more and more
sensitive do you see that affecting
patient management for example would you
continue to treat a cmv positive patient
with viral load results less than lod
yeah
another good question and one that um
[Music]
really does need to be addressed the the
sensitivity of the assays
the analytical sensitivity is quite good
and
may be better
than
certainly some of the laboratory tests
develop tests are deployed and and may
be better than some of the other
results that you would see on other ibd
platforms
um so that that raises the question you
know what would you do if you were
following patients that are on therapy
in my experience using
abbott
running assays for cnb on the avid m2000
platform
typically we'd see dramatic declines
in the viral load during the first seven
days of
institution of therapy
and
the
standard of care in many places would be
to treat
until
you get an undetectable result
that may be more difficult right if
you're using an assay that has a
much lower limit of detection and again
that's going to be something that um
[Music]
will be challenging uh for laboratories
as they move from one platform
to another and
uh with a particular focus on doing
parallel testing on those samples
that have
low or undetectable viral loads
from patients on therapy
thank you so much our next question you
mentioned that you transitioned your ebv
whole blood testing to plasma could you
elaborate what prompted the sample type
change question mark
well
blood has never been one of my favorite
um
whole blood has never been one of my
favorite specimen types for any
viral load
assay it doesn't store well
there are some difficulties
it presents some additional difficulties
for nucleic acid extraction
over plasma
and then you have this annoying problem
with both both viruses both cmd and ebd
uh cadence remain latent
in
white blood cells so if you are
using whole blood then
you're capturing the um
may be capturing latently infected
white blood cells
and
then you find patients at persistent
low levels of both virus could have
persistent low levels of the virus it's
sort of a confounding
thing for many clinicians
not knowing what to do with that whether
that needs to be specifically addressed
in terms of a therapeutic intervention
or whether it just should be ignored
plasma
has been shown certainly for cmv and to
a lesser extent with env to be a better
indicator
um finding and quantifying
um the virus in plasma and the cell-free
component of the blood has found to be
it's found to be in most studies a
better indicator of active viral
replication
than finding and the
target in whole blood
thank you so much dr nolte now that who
international standards are available
for cmv and ebv what additional
information would be needed from a
diagnostic perspective to be able to
define a global threshold example what
parameters drive analytical performance
of transplant assays specifically cmv
amplicon size and extraction
efficiencies are critical when
quantitation across different platforms
are evaluated
yeah that's another good question and i
think many of us in the in the molecular
diagnostic
community thought that
having international standards available
for many of the
viruses for which we monitor viral loads
including ebb and cmv would help
narrow
the difference
between um
[Music]
the different
reagents that are available for
manufacturers and the different
laboratory developed tests that are out
there and they have they have they have
helped
but there are many other components to
go in
to
sort of that assay agreement
that um don't seem to be addressed
by the use of indus
international standards as calibrators
there are different differences that can
be introduced in the assays in terms of
extraction efficiency
target selection is important
and so we
it was an important welcome first step
in terms of assay
alignment if you will
but it hasn't addressed all of the
issues out there and in practice
we still do see
some
greater variations between assays
that have all been calibrated against
international stat standards
than we might have expected
thank you so much for your time today
and your presentation would you like to
provide any closing remarks for our
audience before we close today
no i just want to thank everybody for
their attention i hope
this addressed
many of your questions about
not only
who needs to be monitored for cmv and
ebv
but
all of your questions about the
analytical and the clinical performance
of the habit cmv and ebp essays
well thank you again dr noldie for your
time and for your important research
and i also want to thank lab roots and
our sponsor scientific affairs molecular
diagnostics at abbott underwriting
today's educational webcast and before
we go i want to also thank our audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand laborats will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone bye